so a lot of kids going into next year
the question get asked
well what do you want to do with the
rest of your life what do you want to do
that's a stupid question
do you ask the parent and teacher are
they happy
are they happy with what they're doing
for a living yeah
when our 15 year old gary got made fun
of by teachers i looked them dead in the
face
i did this three different times in high
school and said
are you happy with the way your career
ended
like you're telling me that i'm gonna be
a failure because i got an
f in science like i have a very good
read of what i'm going to do with my
life
yeah i'm going to be a successful
businessman you may be right mrs statz
i remember your names you may be right
mrs stats that i may be a failure
you also may be wrong but before we
guess what's going to happen with me
let's focus on you are you happy with
your life
the foundational aspects of my happiness
is predicated that i do not care what
other people think of me
not because i'm audacious it's because
they i know that they don't fully know
me the same way i don't fully know
anybody
everybody's scared because they're
worried about what their parents older
siblings spouse
partner or best friends are gonna think
about their failure
i don't care when i lose it's my loss
that has nothing to do with you
everybody i know is losing
so if you're casting judgment on what i
failed at that's fine that's
cute you're not doing anything good for
yourself while you're doubting others
i'm just not
interested in your judgment because
everybody sucks at something else too
yeah okay so the re that's where people
are getting crippled they're not doing
things because they
actually care about what other people
think a young pedro
he's moved on pedro he's crushing it on
tick tock by the way oh are you on tick
tock
tick socks and [ __ ] man wait a minute
pedro can just come in like that
you guys i like this place good job
pedro i saw gary vee's videos yeah
talking about tick tock this is maybe
like six months ago yeah and then i got
an account it just shot up
and yeah just crazy stuff man and that's
an example of first tick tock's still
looming tick tock's the first platform
used to be known as musically got bought
it popped three years ago it's popped
back up in the last year and it's the
first platform that has a chance to
really
push instagram as instagram right now is
the establishment in the culture
tick tock may or may not but it's at
enough scale and it's young enough
to do to instagram what instagram did to
facebook
and so you've got to pay attention to it
right now and most people are listening
right now like wait a minute that's what
my 11 year old daughter's on but don't
forget that's what we said about
facebook that's what we said about
instagram
you know these things start young and
then eventually they age up
quality content or quantity of content
and you ask you know why why spread
yourself across
so many different platforms because
you're capable like why did deon sanders
play football and baseball because he
was capable
but most people aren't um
first of all quality needs to be debated
who gets to decide its quality the
creative director
the brand manager who before a piece of
creative sees the day of light
it cannot be decided what kind of
quality it is
we need to understand the agenda of the
creative and so
for me quantity is not debatable i
always tell my team
guys gals if you're going to deliver a
piece of work
three days late that a client was
waiting for that's not a debate
you are three days late that is not
subjective that's black and white
once you deliver that work what she or
he thinks of it
is completely subjective and uh
we see a lot of perfection and a lot of
politics and a lot of subjectivity
which is just hiding in security in this
industry
and so i do not understand how people
don't understand
that we live in a world of 10 to 15
digital
platforms that really control the
attention graph of our society
and for us to not be telling stories
that are relevant
to the 12 15 35 different cohorts that
we could be speaking to
across these five to 15 platforms is
leaving something on the table
and i think agencies and startups and
organizations
need to restructure to be able to be
a quantity and quality player
in today's world but a traditional
creative department
of copywriters and art directors and
senior creatives
debating work and then pitching two
ideas
is not built for a 2019 internet world
which is why they push so hard against
quantity
and and judge it as schizophrenia or not
on brand
spray and pray see what sticks i see it
as
marketing for the sake of getting quant
and qual feedback to do better marketing
i think they have probably just another
minute or two left so uh
let me uh let let me ask you one which
i'm i'm sure you'll probably
get asked a lot which other platforms to
watch at the moment you mentioned tick
tock earlier
is is that the the coming one that you
would argue marketers should be looking
at right now for all the marketers that
are listening knowing the makeup of this
audience
tic toc is important because just
remember what you thought about
instagram and facebook over the last 15
years
it starts super young and then over time
it ages up
and i do believe that we're in the
moment of instagram's prime
instagram has become absolutely the
prime place
much like facebook was in 2011 and i
think when you're in your deep
prime you're in the beginning stages of
being past your prime
and i think that tick-tock is the only
platform
that has that much use at that young of
an age
that has the potential to mature up and
challenge
and so yes but we've also already
mentioned
i think every single person that's
listening to this podcast
should start producing content for
linkedin every one of them
everyone
regardless of whether people love you or
hate you like they want to listen to you
whereas i listen to other people in
business and i just get bored
and i just tune out because it's like a
bit dry i think i think whether you know
i also i thank you i think whether it's
entertainment value i think the one
thing that has been very
happy that i'm very happy about is i
stay in my lane like
i i definitely believe that i know what
i'm talking about because
i mainly only start talking once
something is proven to me that it works
yeah so i think a lot of people right
now are guessing
for the sake of creating content or
maybe striking gold
i appreciate you saying that i really do
think it's also why i stay very narrow
there's a lot i don't talk about seo i
don't talk about
you know global economics i don't talk
about
a lot of things because i'm not educated
on them but i think that uh
staying in your lane of expertise
matters yeah well i think social
i know looking at the content that you
put out i think it's really interesting
because you're very
much in that space and you have to be an
early adopter to say
new platforms like tick tock in
australia they actually recently just
hid
likes on instagram i'm aware which has
been interesting
which i'm a huge advocate of really why
i think that people have become too
uh one-dimensional in knowing what their
audience is looking for
completely predicated on the arbitrary
number of likes
and i think it is limited creativity and
expansion
of people's horizons and i think it's an
extremely healthy
change okay and i'm hoping it becomes a
global permanent change i really do
and i'm somebody who gets a lot of likes
yeah i just think it will be
better for more people
how do you switch off when you are when
you get home and do your switch off
that's the question
i don't switch off but i usually
collapse and go to sleep you know i get
home very late
11 12 is pretty consistent for me
weekdays
so i'm exhausted after 18 hours and i
bring
and i bring a lot of energy all those
hours you know when i think about my
school career
those eight hours i probably put out 40
minutes of energy
and i see people do that at work all the
time they work for nine hours but
they're really working for an hour
um but for me i'm going 15 hours and i'm
going 15
i'm going 14 hours and 52 minutes
so i don't turn off but i think
i just break down and go to sleep so um
yeah i don't i'm never off i'm only on
to something yeah i'm just
things like sports card we were talking
about before those are good distractions
right like when i was flying here
uh today on the 14 hour
15 hour link from la to here i slept
eight hours but the other six hours i
was on ebay looking for arbitrage to buy
soccer cards so i'm not off
but i'm doing something that is not that
serious so that allows me to you know
other you know somebody next to me may
be watching a avengers movie
and that's how they unplug or somebody
else might be playing a game
i tend to unplug by doing more business
[Music]
hey um i'm coming to see you later thank
you i came up we came up here with my
dad because um how are you sir
my dad introduced me to you a couple
years ago he's always been your biggest
fan always preach your stuff
thank you so much so about a year ago i
didn't really
take you on board yep i just can't thank
you enough for the message that you put
out there my name is jack
jack nice to meet you awesome thanks for
saying hello
i wasn't sure whether you're having
downtime i saw you just chilling out and
i was like
let's do it let's sneak it in you're
amazing
let's go i don't get star struck ever
and you're just you're killing me
i'm very flattered jack thank you hi
let's do it this way that way
you can actually see your faces thank
you so much
oh much better
i'm literally shaking right now i'm very
flattered
awesome thank you such a pleasure to
meet you so
thanks for saying hello thank you mother
thank you
i'm not in a in the best place right now
mentally um
i know thank god it's so early yeah
thank god so early you know like you say
i'm honest i believe in that i mean
i i there's there's no better time
to not be in the best place than when
you're under 30. you
literally have your entire life to get
into the best place and i've sort of
come to the point i've been working
full-time as an employment consultant
helping other people find work yes and
i've sort of got to the point where i've
been working so much that i haven't done
any self-care
yes and i'm just like i need to focus on
myself i need to
i've met in my whole 21 years i've never
actually got in touch with myself yeah
i listen there's people who go 80 years
that don't get in touch with themselves
the fact that you're even aware to get
in touch with yourself
at this young of an age in itself is a
real accomplishment
you really need to understand that it's
the truth
jack i'm not trying to be nice getting
to a place where
you think about those things at this
young of an age have that level of
thoughtfulness
you're you're set up for success now it
just becomes a game of
making sure that the things that you're
leaning into are completely predicated
on the things that you understand about
yourself make you actually happy
you know i just um i'm i just i've
always been so
knowledgeable about business and about
um you know
my creative side and i'm just i've
always been torn about which side of me
i go to
so i'm still look one of the things that
i can tell you is
and you know you know this better than
he does and and even we are still young
enough to not fully be there
life is so long the answer is both yeah
you can go eight years on being creative
wake up at 29 and say you know what i
want to make a couple more bucks i don't
want to live in this place anymore
and then go into your business side i
mean i think i think that
people think that they have to make
choices when in reality
they they don't yeah and i think
you're sipping cappuccinos you just
you know you just don't have to you
don't have to make a choice in
perpetuity
make the make a choice right now go all
in
and then maybe that's good forever look
one of the reasons i like leaning into
the creative side
is when you have a business acumen
underneath that creative side
sometimes you end up marrying the two
there's no victories in passiveness
exactly no i gotta run take care
pleasure thank you so much appreciate it
such a
so a lot of kids going into next year
the question get asked
well what do you want to do with the
rest of your life what do you want to do
it's a stupid question
yeah what do you if you're a 17 year old
what do you say to a parent or a teacher
or someone that asks you you ask the
parent and teacher are they happy
are they happy with what they're doing
for a living yep because that's what i
did
when my 14 year old when i was 15 year
old gary got made fun of my teachers i
looked them dead in the face
i did this three different times in high
school and said
are you happy with the way your career
ended
like you're telling me that i'm going to
be a failure because i got an f in
science
like i have a very good read of what i'm
going to do with my life yeah i'm gonna
be a successful businessman
you may be right mrs stats i remember
your names
you may be right mrs stats that i may be
a failure
you also may be wrong but before we
guess what's gonna happen with me
let's focus on you are you happy with
your life
yo what up graham if you got two g's and
you're either under 18
your business has to be about the thing
you love the most
when you're youngest the number one
strategy is to try to start something
around the thing you enjoy the most
because you have the most time to invest
at this point
around that strategy there's nothing
there's nothing greater
in the world than loving what you do and
supporting the lifestyle that you want
and the best way to do that is to start
as early as possible
because you have years that you could
put in to try to get there
it's much harder when you're 42 and have
all these expenses
it's still the right move at 42 as a
side hustle until you can go off of your
actual business
and do it but listen to me and listen to
me good
2gs as a foundation 200 bucks as a
foundation
build a media company around your
biggest passion or
flip stuff around your biggest passion
flip sports cards pokemon cards
sneakers clothes or start the number one
podcast and instagram and youtube
channel around that subject
media or retail around the thing that
drives you the most
have you heard of the tall poppy
syndrome no but it's funny you said that
because three people tweeted that exact
terminology to me on a flight last night
and i was going to google what it meant
but then i got a pop-up because right
now i'm in a cocoon of buying sports
cards
and i've been trying to buy up a bunch
of messy rookie cards and i got a
notification from ebay so i got
sidetracked and i had to go buy it
but i'm thrilled now because now you get
to tell me what it is
till poppy is with your your veto poppy
and everyone else is trying to bring you
down
i see yeah so it's called the tall poppy
scene it's funny i have a saying that
says there's two ways to build the
biggest building one
just be good enough to build the biggest
building in town two
try to tear down everybody else's
building
i very much disrespect people who tear
down buildings
i couldn't be more disrespectful of all
the small poppies
that are wasting all their time trying
to tear down the big poppy instead of
focusing on their own poppy and building
a bigger poppy than somebody else's
and telling that puppy no telling
yeah yeah i mean like to me i'm not just
i'm just not worried about anybody
else's poppy
i don't care how big or small your poppy
is yeah i'm gonna focus on my poppy
and that's what i'm about and if and by
the way here's something else i'm very
proud of
if you go out and build a bigger poppy
i'm your number one fan when i get a lot
of accolades from my angel investing but
i'm often
when i get too much accolades to say hey
did you look at scott belski and chris
sacca they did it better than i did and
i was part of that gush book
so i'm not worried about anybody else's
poppy and if i happen to build a bigger
one then i want
clapping and the cheers for that but if
somebody else builds a bigger one
i'm not booing it i'm admiring it
especially if that poppy didn't use
you know fertilizer that was illegal
[Music]
are you seeing are you still seeing
resistance to your content marketing
methodology or your methodology
yeah and why do you think that is like
are they just lagging because it's hard
right people just don't get it
people get it people don't want to do it
i get that you have to eat properly and
work out every day to have a tremendous
physique
doesn't mean i want to do it twinkies
are fun
sleeping in is fun i'm out here i mean
ninety percent of the stuff that's gonna
be said out there today versus what i
say is gonna be completely contradictory
there is no passive income there is no
[ __ ] shortcut
there is no system bleed out of your
[ __ ] eyes
and provide value and wait 30 years to
build something meaningful
who the [ __ ] wants to hear that
[Music]
there's resistance because it's hard
[Music]
i [ __ ] collapse when i walk in like
when i walk in at 11 or 12 p.m i'm
asleep within eight seconds
i really like what i'm doing
you know how much energy i had in school
dick
i think the more you like it and listen
there's also like
you know that's like me asking you how
you have a great head of hair
like at some level some people just have
dna like i've always had a [ __ ] load of
energy that's just
what i was given right so i also think
for me
specifically the combination of natural
energy that was
handed to me with whatever chemical
infrastructure i have
plus genuinely liking what i do that's
passion and the how is where you get the
energy from bro every single person that
chases
cash over loving the process
ends up far less happy than people think
all of them that's my answer
you got it
[Applause]
thank you thank you so
[Applause]
your much worth
i love you guys
i've been waiting for you long time five
years
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
thank you guys sorry they're pulling me
bye guys
yeah i mean you know sometimes uh people
give me letters
which is always kind of daunting because
they suck at reading
so probably take me 10 to 50 times
longer to read this letter
than most people but other times you
know
i just sometimes don't get through them
sometimes i'm not sure where they are
and other times like tonight where
i don't have to do anything on the way
to the airport
i'm going to read it and in that reading
in those stories
you get a lot of insights to themes or
other things that i use to help and plus
get to deliver on the ambition of the
person handing it to me which is either
being heard or whatever asks they may
have which has often the case so
that's the story of the letter
[Music]
you